[Applause]
well that didn't last long
that's it after six months of joining
the real Amanda seals announced she's
not returning my contract is up at the
real and I did not renew it the 38 year
old actress thought she wasn't able to
express herself properly as a black
woman on the show my soul to be at a
place where I cannot speak to my people
the way they need to be spoken to and
where the people who are speaking to me
in disparaging ways are not being
handled I'm not in a space where I can
as a full black woman have my voice and
my co-workers also have their voices and
where the people at the top are not
respecting the necessity for black
voices to be at the top - Amanda
continued to open up about her exit from
the reel insisting that her departure
had nothing to do with her relationship
with her now former co-host do not try
to create some false dissension between
me and the co-host of the real y'all so
in corny there is a whole pandemic and
an uprising going on and you still can't
find else to do but try and create some
conflict that doesn't exist I did not
unfollow
unfollow Loni love Amanda then gave a
shout out to Tamir amore Housley Jeannie
Mai Loni love and Adrienne Houghton but
y'all don't understand this grown man
gum grown women do grown women business
that's what y'all don't understand I'm
what I do with my business ain't got
nothing to do with them sister Loni
responded with you make me laugh you
make me think you make me a better woman
thank you
et spoke to Adrienne in February where
she praised Amanda as the new addition
to the show I've actually known Amanda
the longest out of anybody else out of
anyone on the panel I've known Amanda
since we both lived in New York I've
always loved who she is I've left how
opinionated she is and that's what we
really what we love on the show is
having women that have strong opinions
yeah and I bring a different perspective
[Music]